bonsoir je vous propose ce soir
d'écouter une audition qui s'est déroulé
ici au sénat ce matin sur l'évolution de
la pêche maritime le thème comment
concilier exploitation et préservation
des ressources halieutiques
alors cette édition est organisée par
l'office parlementaire d'évaluation des
choix scientifiques et technologiques
un organisme présidé par le sénateur
bruno sido qui a pour mission d'informer
le parlement sur ses choix scientifiques
et technologiques alors précisément nous
allons écouter une table ronde sur la
réforme de la politique commune de la
pêche
cette politique commune est elle à la
hauteur des enjeux
ong et producteurs de pêche vont tenter
de répondre à cette question je voudrais
donc tout de suite passé à cette
deuxième table ronde qui devait nous
éclairer sur les effets de la réforme de
la politique commune de la pêche rapport
aux enjeux qui sont en cause
je voulais je voulais y recueillir les
points de vue des différents acteurs
bien sûr les ong les associations qui
sont très bien représentés et puis les
pêcheurs qui n'ont pas cru devoir rester
bonne posture
en général il vaut mieux être présent
quand on débat de deux sujets et avoir
une contradiction sereine et c'est ainsi
que c'était l'esprit de mon rapport
c'est l'esprit de tous les rencontres
que nous avons initié un moment de ce
rapport et c'est l'esprit que j'ai
rencontrés chez les scientifiques aussi
chez beaucoup d'organisation de pêche et
je pensais qu'il y avait de grands
progrès est bon il semble que depuis
quelque temps
le climat soir soit moins - bleu - rouge
je ne sais plus donc j'en prends acte et
la table ronde sera bien sûr limiter au
point de vue des organisations de
protection de l'environnement qui ont
qui sont fait entendre avec force
récemment au moment du vote du parlement
européen dans la politique
à propos de la réglementation de la
pêche profonde et elles ont suscité un
large mouvement d'opinion puisque
l'association bloom représentée par
madame nouvian as tu crois obtenu plus
de huit cent mille signatures de soutien
sa pétition contre le chalutage en eau
profonde
c'est un chef considérable qui témoigne
d'une véritable prise de conscience
collective et dont nous politique nous
serions faire abstraction je regrette
que encore une fois je romiti ait cru
devoir décliner notre notre invitation
falaise et défendre le point de vue des
acteurs de la pêche sans lesquelles on
ne peut rien faire mais nous n'allons
pas pour autant interdire de parole des
organisations qu'ils ont présentée je
vais donc leur donner la parole
dans un premier temps ce sera madame
élise peut être qui je crois est une
ancienne de l'université de bretagne
occidentale
une ancienne élève de l'université
d'agrocampus ouest halieutiques situées
du côté de brest
avesnes là une antenne à brest
la une en tête je suis un peu chauvin
est là parce que je vous remercie
monsieur claque pour l'invitation et
pour nous laisser l'opportunité de de
nous exprimer au cours de cet échange de
cette audition parce qu'en effet on
parle depuis ce matin de pêche déco
titane marins et de poisson et le
poisson est un bien commun donc ça qu'en
tant que représentants de la société
civile on est content d'être autour de
la table ça nous semble indispensable et
nécessaire pour justement avoir des
débats complet donc on ne peut dans ce
cas là que regretter en effet l'absence
de des représentants de la profession
donc sur la thématique que vous
souhaitez qu'on aborde donc sur la
réforme de la politique commune de la
pêche est elle à la hauteur des enjeux
c'est vrai que c'est une réelle question
dans un premier temps on peut peut-être
revenir sur l'origine de cette réforme
se dire que c'était une réforme
nécessaire nécessaire dans le sens où
comme vous le disais dans votre rapport
le constat de trente années de politique
commune de la tène de la pêche était
plutôt amer dans le sens où on avait un
réel constat d'échec pourquoi parce que
la politique avec quatre piliers
4 4 4 piliers on va dire que l'on peut
regretter qui était un pilier pollue
productiviste la pêche a été calquée sur
un modèle agricole alors que un poisson
ne se produit pas il se capture dans le
cadre de la pêche
donc on est dans le cadre d'une activité
de paye est donc à partir là quand on
essaye d'établir des modèles basés sur
une production en effet on arriva à
certaines limites
la politique commune des pêches était
aussi jusqu'à présent très centralisé
c'était une politique qui était basée
sur une des décisions prises
essentiellement à bruxelles qui était
donc loin du terrain et qui du coup
qu'on promet de fait des départs
l'acceptabilité et la pertinence des
différentes mesures qui peuvent être
appliqués de suite était une politique
qui étaient menés à court terme et alors
que la pêche tant pour la ressource que
pour les pêcheurs nécessite une vision à
long terme et enfin c'était une
politique basée comme on l'a vu
essentiellement sur du gaspillage une
gaspillage de ressources avec donc on en
a longuement discuté cette politique dès
cette pratique des rejets mais également
un gaspillage financier puisque de
nombreuses subventions a été utilisé à
mauvais escient et ont généré de la
surcapacité et donc les problèmes qu'on
lui connaît les conséquences de cette
politique sont ceux qu'on a pu voir ce
matin c'est une érosion de la
biodiversité c'est une surexploitation
des stocks
donc je ne vais pas revenir sur ce qui a
déjà été présenté sur le sujet mais il
ya un réel problème aujourd'hui de
surexploitation des stocks même si on
peut reconnaître que pour certains
stocks
la tendance semble s'améliorer mais
globalement on est quand même encore
dans une situation de stocks
surexploités la commission le rappelait
encore en 2013 il ya 39 % des stocks
connu en atlantique nord est qui sont
surexploités 88% pour la méditerranée
donc c'est quand même une situation de
laquelle on peut se satisfaire
mais au delà des conséquences
environnementales il y avait également
aussi des conséquences
social et économique quand on voit que
depuis les années 50 on a perdu deux
tiers des emplois marin on a perdu 35%
des entreprises de pêche on se dit que
là aussi il ya un échec de cette
politique commune de la pêche donc face
à ça en effet une réforme était
nécessaire il a fallu revoir un peu les
règles le fonctionnement des politiques
des pêches pour avoir une politique
plutôt basée justement sur d'une part un
peu l'urgence la reconstitution des
stocks est d'avoir une ressource scène
qui soit exploitable exploitables
durablement mais aussi donc une réforme
qui puisse mettre fin à la surcapacité
la surcapacité génère de la surpêche
génère aussi un manque de rentabilité
une réforme également qui met fin aux
subventions nuisibles qui mentionne
nuisible aux écosystèmes mais également
aux pêcheurs une réforme qui doit avec
une nouvelle politique des pêches qui
doivent mettre fin des pratiques non
durables que ce soit les pratiquants
d'impact sur les impacts les écosystèmes
qui génère des rejets et enfin donc une
réforme était nécessaire pour mettre en
oeuvre justement une gestion au plus
proche du terrain et intégrant
l'ensemble des parties prenantes puisque
comme le rappelait notre curi c'est
l'intégration de l'ensemble des parties
prenantes prenantes qui permet une
réelle bonne gestion de la ressource
donc face à cela est ce que la réforme
de la pcp a répondu à tous ces enjeux
regardons nous regardons les résultats
qu'on a aujourd'hui puisque les
règlements de base est aujourd'hui
publié le règlement de base donc dans
cette nouvelle pcp on va dire que
globalement il ya une tendance positive
la politique commune des pêches va vers
du mieux mais il ya quand même quelques
points négatifs que je souhaiterais
souligner aujourd'hui à la tradition
veut qu'on commence par un négatif et je
viendrai sont positifs ensuite nous
inquiétez pas mais c'est vrai qu'un des
points négatifs de cette politique
commune à pêche c'est qu'en fait en
termes d'objectifs de reconstitution des
stocks qui est quand même genre à plier
un gros enjeu pour pour la politique
commune de la pêche
l'objectif a été fixé à minima c'est à
dire que j'ai réduit l'objectif fixé je
vais pas revenir sur le débat qui a eu
sur le rendement maximal durable mais
l'objectif qui a été fixé ne garantit
pas une reconstitution des stocks d'ici
à 2020 voire même plus tard donc c'est
quand même c'est quand même un gros
point noir pour cette nouvelle politique
commune de la pêche
on aurait pu et on aurait dû aller plus
loin dans les objectifs et dans
l'ambition de cette politique commune de
la pêche
mais heureusement cette politique
apporte quand même du mieux
cette nouvelle pcp apporte des choses
positives on peut penser notamment donc
c'est vrai qu'on a eu aujourd'hui une
valeur de belles présentations sur
l'importance de la science dans la
gestion de la pêche et dans la
connaissance du milieu marin la nouvelle
politique commune des pêches impose le
respect des avis scientifiques ce qui
est une très bonne chose notamment quand
on sait que jusqu'à présent sont par
exemple sur les dix dernières années
seuls 13% l'état quelques enfin 13% des
tac et quotas à respecter les avis
scientifiques le reste était souvent au
delà des avis scientifiques
donc on espère que cette nouvelle pcp
puisse justement améliorer un meilleur
respect vraiment une gestion basée sur
les avis scientifiques non seulement
pour les mesures connues comme les tac
et quotas mais également pour cette
approche écosystémique dont on parle
beaucoup mais qui dans les faits se
concrétise très peu donc on espère
vraiment que cette nouvelle politique
commune de la pêche qui mêle approche
écosystémique en avant va vraiment
apporter une réelle une réelle que l'on
va espérait vraiment que les
gestionnaires vont se saisir de cette
approche écosystémique pour la gestion
des pêches notamment tout à l'heure dé
didier gasquet faisait référence à l'
approche par flottille parce que souvent
l'approché co systémique est mise de
côté mis à part parce que de par sa
complexité
quand on a aujourd'hui des éléments qui
nous permettrait de nous rapprocher de
cette gestion écosystémique et la proche
parent floating sait des choses décale
les gestionnaires devraient se saisir un
autre point positif donc au delà de une
meilleure intégration de la science
dans cette nouvelle pcp c'est le
développement des plans pluriannuels de
gestion à une saison que dans votre
rapport vous ce levier le problème de
vision à court terme de la gestion des
pêches et là en fait c'est plan
pluriannuel de gestion sont un peu la
colonne vertébrale de cette nouvelle pcp
qui vont permettre justement d'avoir une
approche par pêcheries et qui vont
répondre à différents besoins d'une part
un besoin d'avoir une gestion au plus
proche des réalités du terrain avec
intégrant l'ensemble des acteurs donc
non seulement les pêcheurs qu'il faut
remettre au centre de la gestion mais
également les autres parties prenantes
l'administration les scientifiques les
la société civile pour définir ensemble
les mesures de gestion par pêcheries et
enfin donc c'est aussi ses plans
pluriannuels de gestion répondent à un
autre besoin qu'il a la vision à plus
long terme justement d'éviter de rester
dans cette gestion à court terme et
d'offrir une visibilité à long terme
pour les pour les différentes pêcheries
un autre point également positif de
cette nouvelle pcp c'est qu'elle propose
une pêche moins impactante dans sa
globalité c'est à dire qu'il y a ce que
j'entends par une pêche moins impactante
il ya trois différents volets qui sont
intégrés dans cette politique commune
des pêches
c'est la question des rejets en effet
cette nouvelle pcp al'avantage de
vraiment prendre à bras le corps le
problème des rejets avec l'obligation
débarquement dont on a longuement
discuté mais en effet c'est une
obligation débarquement qui doit être
accompagnée d'une mesure en amont qui
est l'amélioration de la sélectivité des
engins et des pratiques pour justement
éviter ces captures accessoires
à la base il ya ce premier point déroger
il ya également aussi la mise en place
de zones de reconstitution des stocks de
poissons qui est un point très positif
également de cette réforme et enfin donc
sur cette pêche moins impactante
globalement il ya la mise en place de
nouveaux critères d'accès à la ressource
est à dire que maintenant les états
membres devront mettre en place des
objectifs et des critères d'accès
objectifs et transparents favorisant les
pêches les moins impactante à la
ressource
on pourra voir l'accès à la ressource
donc c'est quand même globalement
positif
et enfin un dernier point qui nous
semble très positif également c'est que
cette nouvelle pcp devrait mettre fin à
la surcapacité
avec cette nouvelle avec cette nouvelle
politique les états membres vont être
obligés d'établir un rapport donc
d'évaluer leur capacité et de la mettre
en adéquation avec les possibilités de
pêche c'est à dire que ils devront
identifier les zones surcapacitaire
établir des plans d'action afin
justement de supprimer la surcapacité et
d'avoir une capacité de pêche en
adéquation avec ce que le milieu est
capable de fournir et donc c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment sur ce point que
je vais la cité c'est que même si tu
alors je suis je cite l exemple du rnd
qui aurait dû aller plus loin dans cette
réforme
donc on voit qu'il ya quand même
quelques bémols mais globalement la
nouvelle politique commune des pêches va
va vers du mieux va vers du positif et
donc on voit que cette nouvelle pcp
pourrait répondre à la question
justement de concilier exploitation et
préservation de la ressource
si elle est bien appliquée et janvier à
la salle aux problèmes d'aujourd'hui
c'est de dire que le cadre européen
aujourd'hui a été fixé le fait en donc
quel est l'instrument financier qui va
accompagner cette pcp devrait être très
rapidement aussi
achevée donc maintenant s'il va dépendre
maintenant des états membres de la bonne
application est la bonne mise en oeuvre
de cette politique commune de la pêche
est aujourd'hui donc c'est vrai que les
états membres ont les outils avec cette
nouvelle pcp et son nouveau fait encore
en les outils pour la mise en oeuvre
d'une pêche durable qui soit
respectueuse de l'environnement mais
également rentable et pourvoyeuse
d'emplois laisse vraiment bon en gros
les clés en main pour justement mettre
en oeuvre cette politique commune de la
pêche pour développer une pêche durable
au niveau national sauf qu'à l'heure
actuelle on peut constater sa accepter
non citées dans le rapport de la cour
des comptes que la politique notamment
en france la politique des pêche était
essentiellement une gestion politique de
gestion de crise un peu la politique du
pansement
donc on essayait de répondre à des
crises par départ des subventions par
certaines décisions et une vision claire
et stratégiques
de quel est l'avenir que l'on souhaite
offrir à la pêche a ses défauts en
france et c'est la ressource et les
pêcheurs qui ont les premiers pâtit donc
aujourd'hui on espère vraiment que la
france va pouvoir développer cette
vision stratégique qui aujourd'hui n'est
pas connu on ne sait pas si elle existe
mais en tout cas on ne la connaît pas et
donc on assiste vraiment la france avoir
une vision
pour l'avenir de l'appel gens parlent
beaucoup du navire du futur mais qu'en
est il de la pêche du futur vraiment
quelle est la bêche que la france
souhaite avoir pour les 5 10 15
prochaines années et pour cela nous
c'est vrai que on assiste tout à fait
sur le fait que cette vision devrait
être établi de manière transparente et
objective avec l'ensemble des parties
prenantes et nous sommes tout à fait
ouverts à participer à la définition de
cette vision je vous remercie madame
merci madame je vais passer la parole
madame bourges le droit de lever f
oui moi je représente greenpeace mais on
est prêts on s'entend bien avec le
péquenot gwl merci beaucoup monsieur le
sénateur pour votre invitation
du coup je vais commencer en disant que
je souscris pleinement au constat qui a
été présentée par par élise sur
l'ensemble de la pcp je vais moi me
concentrer sur un point particulier que
personne n'a abordé jusqu'ici ou à peine
et qui fait écho à l'un des points
centraux que vous évoquez dans votre
rapport de 2008 qui est celui du système
des quotas et plus généralement de
l'accès à la ressource
donc dans votre rapport vous présenter
les limites du système actuel tant au
niveau européen que national d'ailleurs
et notamment vous soulignez
le fait que en france est toujours au
niveau européen aussi la répartition des
quotas est fondée principalement sur les
intériorité où les droits historiques et
en 2008 votre rapport conclut et qu'il
n'existait pas d'insister incitations
réglementaires a développé une pratique
durable en tout cas ça n'existait pas
dans la façon dont les quotas étaient
été distribués et de fait la nouvelle
pcp qui a été adopté récemment offre
désormais une opportunité de changer cet
état de fait puisque la nouvelle
réglementation de base fixe un objectif
clair pour les activités de pêche
elles doivent être menées de manière à
assurer leur durabilité
d'un point de vue environnemental donc
on sort du schéma de l'ancien pcp et des
anciennes pressé ppcp de la trentaine
d'années qui vient de s'écouler dans
lesquelles les objectifs de la politique
de pêche était non hiérarchisée et
parfois contradictoires entre là on a un
cap clair qui est établi sur la
durabilité durabilité environnementale
des activités de pêche donc élise à un
parler des différentes mesures qui
pouvaient être mises en oeuvre pour
atteindre 7,7 durabilité
environnementale donc voilà la réduction
des rejets l'atteinte du rmt et si
possible aller au delà
je reviendrai pas dessus en détail il ya
une mesure qui devrait retenir
l'attention des décideurs politiques et
des parties prenantes dans cette
nouvelle pcp
ces mesures qui s'adressent aux états
membres pour qu'ils revoient le système
d'allocation des droits de pêche
vous avez juste faire une parenthèse ici
quand je parle de droits de pêche
je ne parle pas seulement de cottages
parle aussi de licence je parle vraiment
de comment on accède à la ressource et
droits de pêche dont
ma bouche ça veut pas dire droit privé
ou commercialisable là la commission
européenne avait essayé dans un premier
temps pendant le processus d'élaboration
de la pcp de répondre à la question de
la surcapacité en imposant en tentant
d'imposer aux états membres et aux
parlementaires le système des quotas
individuels transférables
ce qui n'a pas marché ce dont se
félicite les ong ici présente et si
l'individualisation des quotas peut être
une piste intéressante en tout cas leur
commercialisation pose le problème de la
privatisation une ressource commune et
de la concentration dans la pêche dans
les mains de quelques-uns
voilà parenthèse refermée sur ce point
la tactique de la commission d'essayer
d'imposer les cuites et n'a pas
fonctionné mais le résultat du travail
en trilogue de la commission des
parlementaires européens et des
ministres en charge des pêches est
plutôt intéressant et c'est l'article 17
de la nouvelle pcp qui propose une
nouvelle façon de faire et qui demande
aux états membres à partir du 1er
janvier 2014 donc on y est d'utiliser
des critères transparents et objectifs y
compris des critères à caractère
environnemental et social et économique
dans l'attribution des possibilités de
pêche par les états membres
de même les états membres doivent
s'efforcer de proposer des incitations
destiné aux navires de pêche qui
déploient des endroits des engins
sélectif ou qui utilisent des techniques
de pêche ayant des incidences réduite
sur l'environnement donc cet article il
est vraiment important dans le sens où
il propose un véritable schéma de
réforme de l'accès à la ressource pour
les professionnels il proposait il
impose puisque c'est ici c'est une
réglementation à mettre en oeuvre et ne
c'est intéressant aussi noté que le
système nouveau système doit être
transparent puisque la réglementation
française pour la répandre la
répartition des quotas existent
aujourd'hui mais sa mise en oeuvre
demeure relativement opaque
il est difficile par exemple de savoir
selon quels critères exacts un sou
quotas qui est attribué à une op et
d'istres
bus entre ces différents adhérents ça
reste assez difficile à comprendre
savoir c'est très peu transparent mais
le manque de transparence du système
actuel est forcément un frein au
développement d'un modèle nouveau
puisque la priorité c'est de faire la
lumière sur comment ça marche
aujourd'hui pour connaître les
faiblesses du système actuel et pouvoir
y paraît avec des garde-fous adapté dans
le nouveau système
même si ce système et peu transparent il
y en a il ya un élément qui est bien
connu qui est celui du poids des
intériorités dans l'attribution des
quotas et articuler la répartition des
quotas uniquement enfin quasi uniquement
sur les intériorité maintient un statu
quo qui n'est plus possible de soutenir
étant donné que un grand nombre de
stocks et de poissons demeure dans un
état biologique
voilà plus que critique et que la
rentabilité économique de nombreux
d'armement
est elle aussi déplorable donc on peut
pas rester dans ce statu quo qui est
alimenté par le recours systématique aux
intériorité pour donner droit de pêcher
à ce qu'ils pêchaient déjà à vendre
voilà donc la mise en oeuvre de
l'article 17
elle est certes une obligation
réglementaire mais je pense qu'il serait
intéressant de l'a22 la prendre comme
une opportunité à saisir une chance pour
instaurer un cadre qui favorise les
activités de pêche les plus durables ce
cadre n'existant pas aujourd'hui donc
nous savons que l'administration
française a d'ores et déjà entrepris la
révision de l'arrêté de 2006 qui décrit
le mode de répartition et de gestion
collective des quotas et il nous pensons
qu'il est urgent d'élargir ce travail en
slim il se limitant pas au contenu de
l'arrêté de 2006
notamment parce que plusieurs stocks ne
sont pas soumis aux quotas dont la
quasi-totalité des stocks de
méditerranée par exemple et ils méritent
ces stocks mérite aussi qu'on se penche
sur la façon dont on les gère 2 par
l'accès à la ressource
donc il s'agit d'un travail de fond qui
pourrait engager une transition vers un
modèle de plage plus durable en assurant
notamment un rééquilibrage dans l'accès
aux ressources en faveur de la petite
pêche côtière durable dont les armements
sont économiquement rentable et qui
produisent des poissons de qualité qui
se vendent plutôt bien sur le marché
alors il s'agit pas de mettre fin à la
pratique de la pêche industrielle ou de
la pêche des désarmements intermédiaire
c'est pas là mon propos puisque mettre
ton à la pêche dans la bande côtière
serait évidemment un non sens économique
et écologique
mais cela étant on est dans un état de
fait aujourd'hui où un rééquilibrage est
nécessaire et notamment dans le cadre
d'une réduction de la capacité qui est
inévitable qui a été souligné par le
panel de scientifiques qui est souligné
dans votre rapport de 2008 qui est un
impératif de l'appcp de réduire cette
capacité ne peut pas le faire n'importe
comment et dans le cadre de cette
réduction de capacité il serait
intéressant de faire une place à ceux
qui ont les meilleures pratiques
voilà
et notamment des pratiques sociales
puisque c'est ce que dit l'article 17
c'est que désormais les critères
utilisés pour répartir les droits
d'accès doivent intégrer une dimension
sociale et économique
et on sait que la petite pêche fournit
plus d'emplois par tonne de poissons
pêchés que la grande pêche industrielle
en tout cas en france donc là la mise en
oeuvre de ce chantier de réforme sans la
restreindre à la question des quotas est
une nécessité et j'illustrerai le propos
par un exemple qui est en train de se
passer aujourd'hui qui est celui de la
gestion du bar le bar est une espèce qui
n'est pas sous quotas le bar est une
espèce dont le stock est en train de
s'effondrer en fin de vraiment diminué
très fortement et donc la question se
pose de savoir quelles mesures de
gestion
on met en place pour éviter que le stock
ne finisse par par s'effondrer
donc est ce qu on le met sous quotas ou
pas c'est une question est ce qu'on
ferme la pêche pendant les périodes de
reproduction est ce qu'on limite
l'activité de certains engins par
rapport à d'autres comment on organise
le partage avec les flottes des autres
pays c'est autant de questions que les
professionnels sont en train de se poser
aujourd'hui ils n'ont pas tous le même
avis sur la question et ça je ne sais
pas si tout le monde est au courant que
les professionnels n'ont pas tous le
même avis sur la question
donc voilà c'est cet exemple montre
qu'il est important aujourd'hui de se
pencher sur sur la question de la
réforme des droits d'accès aux
ressources et avec tout le monde
pour mener cette réforme qui serait
structurantes afin qu'ils seraient très
déterminante dans le futur de la pêche
française évidemment il faut savoir
quelle est la vision du gouvernement
pour la pêche française sur le long
terme et là je rebondis sur les propos
d'élise et voilà enfin je redis la même
chose c'est à dire que cette vision si
elle existe n'est pas partagée on l'a on
ne la connaît pas
encore une fois confl cf le rapport de
la cour des comptes sur comment est
utilisé l'argent public et et voilà et
l'application de la gestion de crise
comme comme pilier de la politique des
pêches
il faut absolument sortir de ça et
pouvoir connaître la vision du
gouvernement pour le secteur de la pêche
en france
au delà de 2017 c'est à dire dans dix
ans dans 20 ans ces questions là qu'il
faut qu'on se pose est la préoccupation
majeure aujourd'hui quand on rencontre
les décideurs politiques différents
ministres sur le sujet ou députés où
c'est là c'est la préservation des
emplois
c'est vraiment ce qu'il ressort et c'est
compréhensible c'est c'est vraiment le
seul grille de lecture qui est appliquée
aujourd'hui
or on ne peut pas garantir que la pêche
sera un secteur qui sera toujours
pourvoyeur d'emplois si on ne se donne
pas les moyens d'atteindre les objectifs
de la pcp
c'est à dire une pêche durable d'un
point de vue environnemental qui
garantisse sa rentabilité économique sur
le long terme
cela dit un des points positifs de la
pcp qui a été récemment adopté ça a été
la participation de nouveaux acteurs
dans son processus d'élaboration à
commencer évidemment par le parlement
européen qui jusqu'ici n'avait pas son
mot à dire sur les politiques de pêche
dire que tous les élus qui représentent
le peuple d'europe n'avaient pas leur
mot à dire sur la façon dont devaient
gérer un bien commun alors maintenant
ils peuvent ils peuvent donner leur avis
et on le prend en compte ce qui est une
bonne chose
les ong ont énormément participé au
processus d'élaboration de la pcp est
également aussi des nouveaux acteurs
qu'on m'avait pas vu jusqu'ici qui sont
les représentants de la petite pêche qui
se sont restreints récemment structurée
au niveau français au sein de la plate
forme de la petite pêche française mais
également au niveau européen au sein
d'une association qui s'appelle life
pour laurine pacte fichman a fui en
europe voilà est le résultat de
l'intégration de ces nouveaux de ces
nouveaux de ces nouvelles parties
prenantes dans le dialogue et le débat
c'est une pcp qui globalement va dans le
va dans le bon sens qui est cohérente
ambitieuse et qui a su y rares cheese et
ses objectifs en affirmant que la bonne
santé économique du secteur repose sur
la bonne santé écologique des
écosystèmes marins et donc il serait
très positif que le dialogue avec
l'ensemble des acteurs puisse être
maintenu et donc évidemment je regrette
le fait que les représentants du conseil
national de la pêche soit soit parti ce
matin parce que je pense que ce dialogue
est cruciale si on veut mener à bien une
réforme des droits d'accès à la
ressource et on attend en tant que ong
de la part de l'administration des
pêches et du ministre en charge de la
pêche ou de son successeur
une décision pour ouvrir ce travail qui
mérite la participation de l'ensemble
des acteurs
je remercie madame je pense que vous
aurez peut-être des commencement de
réponse tout à l'heure madame nouvian
merci beaucoup
alors c'est vrai que le thème
aujourd'hui c'était la pcp est en fait
le règlement pêche profonde est toujours
un peu l'enfant mal lotis de de cette
question puisque c'est un petit
règlement qui est beaucoup plus récent
qui date de 2002 qui est aujourd'hui en
cours de réforme et du coup en comme on
connaît assez bien chez blum le
règlement empêche profond n'est que pour
le coup contrairement à la pcp la
réforme n'est pas terminée elle est en
cours je me suis dit que je n'allais pas
vous parler de tcp puisque je n'étais
pas compétente de ça mais plutôt 2 du
règlement pêche profonde ce dossier en
effet assez je pense emblématiques même
si les récents demain d'une grande
difficulté qu'on a eu à poser un constat
et monsieur cléac'h faisait partie des
suites de la du grenelle de la mer avec
une commission qui est -ce qui est assez
mal déroulé et en même temps depuis on a
quand même fait du chemin
les choses ont avancé puisque évidemment
les pêches profondes sont
particulièrement problématiques les
espèces évidemment il n'y a pas de
lumière les milieux sont extrêmement
vulnérables du fait de l'absence de
lumière et donc du très faible niveau de
de nourriture disponible pour les
organismes
donc on a de faibles taux de
reproductivité des fécondité faible
décroissance qui sont très lentes des
longévités qui sont extrêmes donc les
problèmes qui ont été décrits par les
chercheurs aujourd'hui sur l'est les
difficultés à atteindre la rentabilité
et une exploitation durable se pose
particulièrement de façon cruciale avec
les pêches profondes
puisqu'il faut aller chercher plus loin
plus profondément une ressource qui est
particulièrement vulnérable donc le
règlement pêche profonde et règlements
qui est donc séparée du reste et qui est
en cours de réforme et la commission
européenne a proposé des mesures fortes
pour essayer de régler des problèmes qui
se posent de façon tout à fait criante
et l'une de ses propositions c'était
d'interdire le chalutage profond
la proposition de la commission
européenne c'est une profession qui
était basée sur une définition des
espèces profondes sur par rapport à un
pourcentage par rapport aux captures
globale du navire au parlement européen
le rapporteur arseni sans commission
pêche à proposer une interdiction baiser
sur une profondeur les chercheurs disent
que les océans profond commence à 200
mètres de profondeur parce qu'il n'y a
plus de lumière mais 200 m avec un beau
coup de pêche aujourd'hui donc la
proposition du parlement la première
proposition c'était d'interdire le
chalutage profond donc d'interdire une
méthode de pêche et non pas toute la
pêche jeu insiste sur ce point
au delà de 400 mètres de profondeur
cette option n'a pas été retenue par la
commission pêche et en vue de la du vote
en plénière du parlement c'est une
interdiction encore plus profonde qui a
été proposé à 600 mètres de profondeur
qui a été donc le vote a été perdu en
fait pour cette interdiction de la
méthode de pêche un oeuf voie après qui
a un effet après des députés vont
changer leur vote donc dans les archives
du parlement finalement le parlement a
voté l'interdiction du chalutage profond
mais le processus
absolument légale indique le vote a été
perdu en revanche le conseil donc les
états membres de l'europe sont en train
de discuter de ce dossier qui n'a pas
été discutée pendant très longtemps
pendant plus d'un an et demi depuis la
proposition de la commission européenne
donc un temps quasiment record de
blocage du dossier et en même temps le
l'agenda était très chargée avec la pcp
il fait amp donc bon maintenant on y est
enfin
donc c'est très important et on voit que
de cette situation de blocage qui était
qu'il ya karting caractérisé le débat en
france pendant de nombreuses années
depuis le grenelle de la mer
on a enfin notamment grâce à la
mobilisation des citoyens qui a été en
effet très forte par le biais de la
pétition qu'on a qu'on a mise en ligne
mais pas seulement puisque je j'insiste
sur le fait que nous avions fait un
sondage bva
en fait sur la volonté des français que
de voir leur président de la république
porté cette interdiction soutenir
l'interdiction du chalutage profond
telle qu'elle avait été proposée par la
commission européenne et ce sondage
s'est arrêtée au moment où cette jeune
femme a mis en ligne sa bd qui devenu
célèbre sur le chalutage profond et donc
le sondage donnait avant le 18 novembre
avant la mise en ligne de la bd que 71%
des français désiraient que monsieur
hollande soutienne l'interdiction du
chalutage profond donc ça correspond et
ça montre qu'en effet la société civile
s'intéresse aussi à l'impact de nos
modes de production sur l'ensemble de la
des écosystèmes et donc on refuse en
gros des pêches qui sont associés à des
coûts trop élevés c'est en son sein que
le message est intéressant et les ong
ont salué la décision du groupe
intermarché qui évidemment l'acteur le
plus important en france pour cette
pêche au chalut profond est le 30
janvier ou le 31 janvier exactement de
vendredi matin donc il ya très peu de
temps intermarché a annoncé que ces
bateaux allaient se limiter à 800 mètres
de profondeur d'ici un an donc ils ont
vraiment étudier leur cas pour essayer
de conserver en effet un volume de
poissons ils ont besoin donc leur
activité ne pas la mettre en péril ne
surtout pas mettre en péril l'emploi
puisque en effet celle après la
préoccupation principale des
vue notamment l'homme dans le territoire
et notamment ce port de lorient qui
était plus dépendant que les autres des
espèces profondes même si celles ci ne
représentent que 3% de l'ensemble des
des poissons qui sont transformés dans
sur le port de lorient
il représente quand même une partie
importante de la criée donc voilà
intermarché en faisant cette annonce a
montré qu'on pouvait négocier avec les
ong qu'on pouvait discuter que même si
on prenait parfois des positions dures
et dont on était capable de revenir à
des choses négocier des compromis de
réel compromis
bien entendu pour nous il 100 m c'est
trop profond dans le meilleur des mondes
il faudrait que ces ces chats lui
remonte et peut-être que cette
discussion va avoir lieu puisque nous
allons entamer un dialogue avec cette
enseigne est avec leurs flottes de pêche
pour essayer d'aller dans le sens de
l'esprit d'ailleurs de l'appcp c'est à
dire une collaboration plus forte avec
le secteur donc je ne fais pas réitéré
le fait que je suis vraiment très déçu
que le secteur ne soit pas là parce
qu'en fait j'avais l'intention justement
de tendre la main
c'est à dire désire maintenant est ce
qu'on est capable de transformer nos
rapports pour essayer d'aller vers plus
de comme avec l'administration
d'ailleurs de deux d'aller vers plus de
collaboration plus de transparence pour
aller vers de là on va dire des choses
qui sont et objective et raisonnable et
interdire le chalutage profond comme
méthode de pêche au delà de 800 mètres
de profondeur aujourd'hui c'est vraiment
une mesure raisonnable c'est-à-dire que
la crainte que j'ai pour le l'issue de
ce règlement pêches profondes au niveau
européen ce serait que les législateurs
se retrouve à légiférer de façon moins
ambitieuse que ce que le secteur lui
même est capable de faire vous propose
donc notamment en france puisque
intermarché était là la flotte a été
emblématique de cette pêche profonde on
voit qu'intermarché est capable
d'avancer de portée des décisions qui
sont déjà ambitieuse par rapport à leur
réalité de opérationnel eh bien on
attend évidemment à ce que la décision
politique de la france écoute d'abord la
demande des citoyens évidemment prennent
en compte
c'est prennent acte de cette décision du
secteur
il ya eu un jeu insiste sur quelque
chose parce que pendant toute cette
réforme qui n'est pas terminée du
règlement pêches profondes
il ya vraiment eu une crainte très forte
de la part du secteur et des
professionnels que ce précédent
voilà que cette interdiction du
chalutage profond serve de précédent
pour commencer à attaquer tout le chalut
et que ce soit en fait l'objectif caché
des ong de de faire la peau au chalut
chalut de fond en général le chalut de
fond comme on l'a vu ici comme on le
voit dans tous les rapports il est
critiqué pour des impacts écosystémiques
pour sans doute des problèmes aussi de
rentabilité avec une part dans le
chiffre d'affaires du carburant qui est
peut-être tropez le vexin donc une
réalité économique une réalité
écologique dans certaines conditions il
semblerait que le chalut soit
parfaitement acceptable parce que les
écosystèmes sont transformés depuis très
longtemps et se sont stabilisés à un
niveau de productivité pour certaines
espèces
nous on n'est pas des spécialistes du
chalon du chalut en général il ya des
critiques on ne va pas commencer à se
taire sur les critiques qui existe en
revanche il est très clair que ce n'est
pas notre objectif et je le dis vraiment
publiquement je profite de l'opportunité
que vous nous offrez pour dire que ce
n'est pas l'objectif des ong de partir
en guerre contre tous le chez lui après
ça on a fait ce n'est pas dans nos
programmes
ce n'est pas notre objectif et on n'a
aucune intention d'utiliser cette
interdiction du chalutage profond en
europe comme précédent pour se battre
contre tous le chalut notre notre
objectif c'est de faire interdire au
chalutage profond au niveau mondial et
ça va être un combat qui va prendre une
vie et nous ce qu'on veut c'est faire ça
et c'est pas du tout partirait donc
j'espère que les pêcheurs regarde par
internet cette cette intervention et
qu'ils seront rassurés et que de toute
façon ils pourront me prendre au mot
puisque je pense qu'on peut annoncer
cela de façon très ferme
voilà simplement je pense que je n'ai
plus grand chose à ajouter à part qu' on
a entendu parler en france de beaucoup
d'impact sur un grand nombre de navires
etc
et je pense qu'il serait bon on
l'appelle de nos voeux depuis longtemps
une saisine de l'ifremer puisque le
service enfin le système d'information
halieutiques le est 6 h 1 exactement le
nombre de navires qui opère dans quelle
zone a pas
ti avec quel métier et au delà et en
fonction des seuils bathymétriques est
en fait pour avoir vraiment une opinion
très clair et très objectif du nombre de
bateaux qui sont implique un qui serait
affectée par le règlement européen si
l'interdiction du chalutage profond
passé il faudrait savoir en fonction de
certains seuils qui peuvent être
négociés au conseil 400 600 800 m quelle
qu'elles sont le nombre de navires qui
opère aujourd'hui avec des chaluts deux
fonds quelles sont leurs captures
qu'elles sont là par voilà on a la part
des prises accessoires dans leurs
captures se sont donné que son objectif
est qu'ils sont très importantes
et puis pour terminer voilà pour dire
que nous il avait été acté au moment de
la conférence environnementale en
septembre dernier à une table ronde sur
la biodiversité marine qui avait été co
présidée alors par le ministre de la
pêche frédéric cuvillier que la position
française sur le règlement pêches
profondes qui doit être rendu au conseil
à bruxelles pour le 14 février devait
être établi en collaboration et en
association avec justement toutes les
parties prenantes donc les ong sont tout
à fait disposés à discuter cette
position française en espérant que le
secteur soit d'accord pour qu'on ait
comporte cette interdiction du chalutage
profond à une profondeur qui déjà très
élevé mais qui nous semble être un
standard environnementale a minima et
sans lequel on trouverait difficile pour
la france de continuer à afficher des
ambitions très forte en terme de défense
de biodiversité marine en haute mer
parce que c'est compliqué d'aller faire
la leçon entre guillemets au niveau
international aux nations pour leur dire
que c'est nous les champions de la
protection de la biodiversité
quand il s'agit de balayer devant sa
porte en europe avec des mesures
concrètes qui s'applique chez nous et à
nos flottes
on n'est absolument pas d'accord pour
pour prendre des mesures qui a priori
justement d'impact que très très peu de
bateaux est encore intermarché nous a
montré qu'on pouvait ajuster avec
intelligence ces mesures donc voilà nos
espoirs
nous sommes tout à fait au contraire
ouvert au dialogue est très heureux de
voir que ce dialogue quand même a lieu
globalement beaucoup
jusqu'avant donc merci de nous donner
cet espace là merci madame nouvion et
bien vous voyez il ya quand même du
positif on peut garder un peu d'espoir
enfin il reste encore des enjeux lourds
je voudrais donc maintenant à ce stade
de la matinée donné la parole tout
d'abord à eux chefferie yaiche directeur
pour l'atlantique les régions
ultrapériphériques et l'arctique à la
commission européenne pour nous parler
de ce qui est ce qui vient d'être fait
et de l'avenir
merci monsieur le président je me
propose peut être de commencer avec un
très bref constat de la situation
actuelle en 2014 où on a maintenant par
rapport à la situation perçue il y as et
en 2007 dans les rapports qui est le
point de départ de cette édition
nous pensons que aujourd'hui les
arguments qui montre une crise qui
montrait une triste la pêche qui tp
d'être pertinent en 2007 en raison des
stocks surexploités ou épuisés sont
comme moi pertinents aujourd'hui au
moins dans les eaux européennes
on a déjà eu entendu et vu les
les chiffres dans notre présentation
j'ai mis ici un tableau très très simple
qui montre le nombre des stocks pêcher
en conformité avec ce fameux rendement
maximum durable rmd donc la mortalité
des pêches au haut niveau et amd qui est
passé de 6 % en 2015 à soit 61% en 2000
en 2013 60 % des stocks
vous verrez que les lignes se sont
croisés il y à il ya non donc on est
dans une situation actuelle qui montre
une exploitation beaucoup plus durable
que il y à il ya quelques années c'est
pas ce n'est pas dû au hasard c'est ça
résulte un autre avis d'une application
cohérente et est effectif
des instruments de conservation que nous
avons à notre disposition tels que des
plans de gestion à long terme qu'on a
mis en place pour pour pas mal de stock
en difficulté les tac et quotas qu'on a
mentionné un instrument clé qui est
parfois difficile à gérer
difficile à trouver des compromis et des
solutions au conseil des ministres mais
mais mais
on a on a utilisé l'instrument
effectivement dans les années passent et
les limites des forts qui complémentent
c'est à des quotas des mesures
techniques et désormais une chose clé
est que depuis quelques années les
propositions de la commission européenne
pour les cas qui coûta pour les mesures
de gestion des stocks sont basés sur la
science c'est l'avis scientifique
ça ne veut pas dire que les résultats
comme tels que arrêté par les conseils
des ministres sont toujours basés sur
des éléments scientifiques il ya des
jugements à faire des arbitrages à faire
mais le point de départ est toujours la
science et c'est un principe important
qui à mon avis a mené à 7
cette évolution positive donc je passe
peut-être en juste à parler de trois
objectifs de cette réforme de la pêche
de règlement de pêche européenne combien
de combien les conclure et donc d'abord
encore un mot sur ce principe de
rendement maximum durable
c'est clairement un élément clé de la
réforme un objectif clé de la réforme
on vient de le dire déjà donc notre
objectif commun est de atteindre d'ici à
2015 un taux de rendement maximum
durable et donc pour les stocks pour
lesquels ce n'est pas possible sur une
base incrémentale proxy faut plus tard
d'ici 2020 pourquoi cet objectif rnd
aura des bénéfices également économique
on vient de soulever le le lien entre
dans le débat le lien entre la proche
écosystémique et la question du
rendement économique
c'est une histoire très simple on avait
très banal très simple si un pêcheur
c'était de la sphère une pêche auto rmd
il va devenir plus rentable parce que
d'abord la taille des stocks augmentera
dans les moyens terre donc sans peine
plus de poissons à pêcher davantage de
poissons à pêcher deuxième avec des
stocks plus importants l'effort de pêche
diminuera donc
il faut sortir moi fréquemment dépenser
moins de gazole de de ressources pour
pêcher les mêmes quantités la qualité
des captures va augmenter on peut cibler
les poissons que l'on peut pêcher détail
contre le péché et la stabilité la
dépêche va augmenter donc moins deux
abstentions - de fluctuation dans les
quantités et c'est surtout ça ce que le
secteur de pêche souhaite et a besoin
comme comme chaque secteur économique
c'est un degré de stabilité
ça ne se fera pas sans des adoptions
adaptation donc on bien de dire aussi
dans le premier panel que pour quelques
stocks
on aura besoin d'une dune et pour pas
mal de stocks on aura besoin d'une
réduction des prises initial pour
atteindre ce niveau
qui alors va rester stable il y a des
histoires de succès très clair on a
parlé du stock du merlu du nord qui a
déclaré cherry selon les termes d'un
plan de gestion qui a mené à une
réduction des prises assez assez assez
assez substantielle et qui ment qui
maintenant va bien et qui donne des ddd
des récoltes et des prix et des revenus
qui sont qui sont pour beaucoup
supérieurs à ceux qui ceux qui avaient
auparavant
thomas de secret story est donc la
conséquence dans l'ensemble de la
politique européenne de la pêche et que
l'utilisation de l'aide européenne donc
dif du fons tout l or bien de pour la
pêche peut être recentré et mieux ciblée
sur des mesures qui qui qui protège
plutôt davantage l'environnement qui qui
qui qui qui aident à la pêche devenir
encore plus sélectives qui qui qui aide
les pêcheurs artisanale les jeunes donc
moins de subventions tel quel pour le
secteur plus de mesures ciblées parce
que si on empêche à niveau durable le
secteur va être plus viable et plus
profitable donc ça c'est la logique
le deuxième objectif de 2 alors de 2,7
cette réforme est de
établir un équilibre stable et durable
entre la capacité développe réel et les
possibles des possibilités de pêche réel
on a parlé beaucoup de la de l'audit
pression pression de pêche
donc c'est une question d équilibre et
donc d'une part beaucoup reste à faire
mais de l'autre par des progrès
importants ont été réalisés dans ce
domaine depuis 2002 pour pour combler
cet écart entre la capacité de pêche et
les possibilités pêche spécifiquement en
france on peut voir julien tableau que
effectivement tous les indicateurs
montrent une tendance positive en
particulier à partir de 2010
donc à un moment où les revenus ont
augmenté considérablement donc le
secteur semble être selon les chiffres
que nous avons plus rentables et je
pense c'est aussi une conséquence tin
tin tin d'une gestion plus saine et plus
durable de la ressource et donc ceci a
été réalisé après plusieurs années
successives d'adaptation de réduction
des flottes une chose qui ne doit pas se
faire d'une manière brutale radical qui
doit être gérée qui doit être liés à la
conservation de la ressource des stocks
de poisson il y a en france un plan de
gestion et d'ajustement des forts de la
pêche qui a justement ça ça pour
objectif et qui à mon avis
baba encore à titre de nouveau règlement
il faut enfin de la pêche mener à une
attention supplémentaire du secteur
voilà un troisième but alors de la
réforme de la politique commune de la
pêche était de donner plus de
responsabilités et d'autonomie aux états
membres et au secteur kiki cher kiki
cher
le métier est donc pour atteindre cet
objectif nous sommes engagés également à
rétablir le dialogue entre les autorités
les scientifiques et l'industrie il est
important donc la nouvelle pcp de
nouvelle politique commune de la pêche
prévoit de régionaliser un certain
nombre d'instruments tels que les plans
plus les pluri annuel les plans des
rejets donc les plans qui qui qui qui
servent à gérer la l'introduction de
cette fameuse obligation de débarquement
mais aussi des établissements de soins
de de reconstitution des stocks de
poissons et d'autres mesures de
conservation et donc l'idée est
fondamentalement de réduire le niveau
d'intervention intervention détaillé qui
viennent de bruxelles qui vient qui
décide et sans traitement par le conseil
des ministres européens parlent par les
parlements européens par le conseil des
ministres pacolli scission est de le
déléguer à un niveau où les différents
acteurs peuvent travailler ensemble les
acteurs au niveau des états membres dont
les états membres ensemble et les
secteurs qui et qui est impliqué dans ce
processus à travers des conseils de
consultatif qui qui qui eux-mêmes inclus
dans l'industrie des pêches que les ong
tant qu'ils sont qui sont composés de
manière
plus réaliste hic deuxièmement on a fait
de grands progrès concrets dans la
coopération entre entre la science et le
secteur il y avait les mythes que la
science la science des scientifiques
travaillent pour pour la commission
européenne dans le but de faire mal au
secteur pour pour un peu qui n'est pas
lié à la aux internautes et aux intérêts
17 heures c'est un mythe c'est un mythe
c'est pas la réalité
il y a maintenant une bonne pratique de
travailler ensemble entre scientifiques
et professionnels et et ong dans les
conseils régionaux consulter le principe
actif de la pêche qui existent pour tous
les patients de demers la commission
finance un certain nombre de projets de
recherche qui implique tant des parties
prenantes que d'éditer des pêcheurs que
des scientifiques évidemment et la
plupart des réunions scientifiques et
consultatif de la pêche sont maintenant
ouvertes à des observateurs de
l'industrie de la pêche qui inclut les
quelques réunions du du deuxième je vous
donne un exemple le projet dit rich man
qui avait conduit par ifremer qui
atteint pour un projet de recherche
financé par l'union européenne dans le
domaine de la pêche profonde et qui a
qui a fait un grand travail de collecte
de données pour quelques pour quelques
stocks
de la merco fonde surtout le grenat
desrochers le stock du sable noir sur
bath que ce travail de collecte de
données
le cm c'est donc le groupement
international de scientifiques de pêches
à a été en mesure de donner un avis
beaucoup plus qualifiés beaucoup plus
plus plus certain de l'état de ses
stocks
ceci a permis au haut conseil des
ministres européens de pêche bien te
fixer des quotas les tac et quotas plus
précise mais aussi augmentées pour ses
stocks
ceci a à nouveau mené à des revenus pas
mal accrue augmenté pour un certaines
parties du secteur surtout français de
pêche des eaux profondes
donc le gain économique de cette mesure
seul à la fin effectivement pour la
pêche profonde en france a été environ 2
3 millions d'euros j'estime si on
multiplie le nombre de tonnes
supplémentaires avec le prix personnes
donc un résultat très concret d'une d'un
travail de coopération entre
scientifiques et et secteur mais
attention ce travail concerne de stock
chez une liste d'une vingtaine trentaine
de stocks d'eau profonde pour lesquelles
ce travail n'a pas encore été faits pour
lesquels on a très peu de données pour
lesquelles on ne sait pas exactement
qu'est ce qui se passe qu'est ce qu'on
fait et pour lesquels le risque continue
et on vient de le coter de l'entendre
que la méthode de pêcher et l'intensité
des pêches
pour peut faire des dégâts donc à un bon
début mais mais mais beaucoup plus de
travail à faire beaucoup plus attention
à donner aussi à ce secteur est donc
enfin un très très bref le soutien
européen pour que le secteur de la pêche
le législateur européen viennent de
trouver un compromis sur le nouveau
fonds européen pour le maritime et la
pêche qui qui qui qui comprend une
enveloppe de 6,4 milliards d'euros pour
la période 2014 2020 voilà vous êtes
donc puissiez cette table ronde sur
l'avenir de la pêche et en particulier
de la politique commune de la pêche tout
de suite le journal présenté par
delphine girard